[Música]
bienvenidos a kobe 19 los más
vulnerables un programa sobre cómo esta
pandemia afecta a los cientos de
millones de personas que ya vivían en
situaciones de pobreza de hacinamiento o
de marginalidad o se veían obligadas a
emigrar o eran víctimas de guerras y
conflictos mi nombre es andrés suárez
jaramillo comenzamos en una ciudad al
noreste de india donde un hospital
cuenta con un solo doctor en pie se
trata de fumar gaurav un médico
voluntario que decidió quedarse entre
decenas de pacientes porque muchos de
sus colegas se enfermaron y otros se
rehusaron a trabajar lo curioso es que
debe movilizarse por el hospital
escoltado por varios guardias pues
siendo el último médico tiene toda la
presión de las familias sobre sus
hombros la historia a continuación
guardias armados con rifles escoltan al
doctor kumar gaurav el último doctor que
queda en pie en este hospital a orillas
del río ganges los guardias lo protegen
de los propios familiares de los
pacientes muchos de ellos de kobe 19
simplemente se enojan no quieren
detenerse solo quieren visitar a sus
pacientes e incluso se niegan cuando
nuestros guardias los interpela
simplemente irrumpen en nuestras
unidades de cuidados intensivos
para acumar la atención no es fácil en
este hospital de bhagalpur al nororiente
de india muchos de los médicos dieron
positivo por kobe 19 otros se negaron a
trabajar en precarias condiciones y unos
últimos tan solo revisan a algunos
pacientes e inmediatamente se van de
manera que fumar es el único médico
presencial
pérez elsa hay temas emocionales quieren
estar con sus padres y a veces cuando
entienden que sus familiares no lo van a
lograr se desesperan y quieren ver a sus
familiares a toda costa para despedirse
y verlos por última vez
un caso es el de manos su padre de 67
años se contagió de coronavirus a
finales de julio ante la ocupación
saturada de pacientes manos tuvo que
poner a su padre en una sala de 20 camas
que ya estaban llenas a pesar del riesgo
de contagiarse manos yo acompaño todos
los días a su padre en la sala de
emergencias para alimentarlo suplicamos
a las autoridades del hospital que
trasladarán a mi padre a una sala de
kobe 19 y nos decían que se les salía de
las mano
sin que lo cambiarían tan pronto como se
habilitará una cama vacante al final lo
cambiaron de su estado a según kumar el
hospital más cercano con instalaciones
verdaderamente adecuadas para casos
críticos está a 200 km aún así fumar
atiende a pacientes de kobe 19 a pesar
de que sufre de diabetes e hipertensión
dos factores de riesgo de contraer el
coronavirus pero con marc dice que se
siente comprometido con su trabajo de
voluntario
[Música]
si me paro frente a un paciente de kobe
positivo durante dos minutos el supongo
que veo 20 pacientes
tengo una exposición de 40 minutos
frente a pacientes de coronavirus
positivos
fortín en los problemas de atención en
salud son particularmente profundos en
esta región de india la superpoblación
de este gigante asiático sumado a la
precariedad en los servicios de salud de
las zonas rurales han provocado que
india sea el tercer país con más
contagios en el mundo con más de
3.200.000 casos
agosto y septiembre son meses clave para
los migrantes en reino unido- y es que
además del endurecimiento de las
restricciones oficiales para frenar la
migración desde francia hacia suelo
británico también hubo manifestaciones
para apoyar a quienes cruzan el canal de
la mancha y aspiran a una mejor calidad
de vida esto en medio del aumento de la
migración que se ha visto en las últimas
semanas en esta parte del océano
atlántico los detalles los tiene mar y
aclara calle
los migrantes y refugiados son
bienvenidos este fue el clamor de
quienes protestaron en londres a finales
de agosto en frente de la secretaría del
interior de reino unido su manifiesto
fue en contra de las políticas del
gobierno de boris johnson que quiere
endurecer las restricciones para quienes
cruzan el canal de la mancha
[Aplausos]
[Música]
muchos de estos inmigrantes están
huyendo de la guerra por su sexualidad
por discriminaciones están huyendo por
muchas razones diferentes antes
siguen aquí y luchan contra todos los
obstáculos incluso ponen sus vidas en
riesgo en el gobierno les está haciendo
todo más difícil esto es espantoso no
está bien esto es un crimen
la petición es que haya rutas seguras
para los migrantes pues no es nada fácil
cruzar en pequeñas embarcaciones el
canal de la mancha y aún así más
personas han atravesado esta parte del
océano atlántico para llegar al reino
unido
en lo que va del año cerca de 5 mil
migrantes pisaron suelo británico
después de cruzar el canal esta cifra
contrasta con los 2.294 extranjeros que
llegaron al país por la misma vía en
2019 y las estadísticas aumentaron
drásticamente en agosto justo cuando el
gobierno de johnson propuso endurecer
las leyes contra la migración y desplegó
aviones militares y la fuerza naval para
impedir que estas personas llegaran a
reino unido el vehículo somos un país
rico podemos ayudarles y de todos modos
reino unido creó la mitad de los
problemas de los que ellos huyen es
desgarrador no sé dónde está la
compasión esta petición para ayudar a
los migrantes se resume en el llamado de
las manifestaciones en londres que
claman que ningún humano es ilegal
sin multitudinarias protestas debido a
las restricciones por la pandemia en
kobe 19 desde los abarrotados
campamentos en bangladesh los más de
600.000 refugiados rohingya recordaron
la ofensiva militar que hace tres años
expulsó a más de 750.000 miembros de
esta minoría de mianmar hoy siguen sin
poder regresar a sus comunidades debido
a la violencia sistemática y la
persecución por parte del ejército de
mianmar y las milicias budistas marina
sardiña amplia en el siguiente informe
protestas silenciosas en el mayor campo
de refugiados del mundo cutup alone en
bangladesh cuando se cumplen tres años
del éxodo masivo de musulmanes rohingyas
que huían de la violencia sistemática y
la persecución en mi alma
narcisa después de que mi marido fuera
asesinado no tuve más remedio que huir
para salvar a mis hijos durante su
historia se repite entre los más de 750
mil refugiados rohingyas que desde el 25
de agosto de 2017 salieron de sus
hogares ante la ofensiva militar por
parte del ejército de mianmar y milicias
budistas sobre el estado de rakhine
donde vive esta minoría musulmana
el ataque fue calificado por la onu como
una limpieza étnica y posible genocidio
y acabó con la vida de más de 24.000
rohingyas una masacre sin culpables
declarados mientras que los rohingyas
acusan a la líder de mianmar en sal su
kit de terrorista y cómplice
internacional minucioso de ayuda las
agencias de la onu y los gobiernos
internacionales no tuvieron éxito con el
tema de los rohingyas nuestra propuesta
y mensaje es el mismo nuestros
sentimientos sigue
el mismo que antes de vivir life before
hacinados en campamentos improvisados
sin condiciones de salubridad la
situación de estos refugiados la mitad
menores de edad que malviven en
bangladesh se ha agravado con la
pandemia ahora pagando ya no queremos
vivir como refugiados en bangladesh
realmente queremos volver al lugar de
donde venimos a casa mianmar no lo
reconoce como ciudadanos no tienen
acceso a medicinas de educación ni
libertad de movimiento sin garantías de
seguridad y derechos el retorno de estos
apátridas a sus hogares se vislumbra
imposible vamos a américa latina'
aunque venezuela ha enfrentado una
crisis energética desde hace un tiempo a
partir de mayo el desabastecimiento
incrementó y los cilindros de gas
propano son cada vez más escasos esto ha
llevado a miles de personas a conseguir
leña en medio de las ciudades y aprender
a cocinar sin luz y sin gas muy cerca a
la frontera con colombia la familia vega
incorporó un conocimiento particular
para hacerle frente a la falta de gas
veamos la historia con maría clara calle
las técnicas que aprendió como boy scout
ahora les sirven para combatir la
escasez reinaldo vega es un venezolano
que vive en la ciudad de san cristóbal
en el estado de táchira él y sus hijos
salen a recolectar pequeños troncos de
leña en medio de la urbe ante la falta
de bombonas con gas propagó desde mayo
la crisis del gas doméstico se agudizó
en venezuela sumándose a la crisis
energética la mitad de los hogares no
tienen este suministro según una
comisión de expertos liderada por la
oposición pero la familia vega supo
salir adelante y cada quien tiene un rol
para poder cocinar con libros cómo ir a
buscar madera como distribuirse el
trabajo y aquí en la casa hacemos lo
mismo yo busco el trade yo busco la leña
yo me encargo el fuego me esposan
mamados y más en la casa ayudan con la
limpieza ayuda en la preparación de los
alimentos traer el agua ayudar con la
limpieza entonces un trabajo en equipo
que hacemos todo para poder comer con
usando este tipo de medio
adaptan su cocina crearon sus propios
fogones de leña todo con el conocimiento
que reinaldo adquirió siendo un escape
familia vega no es la única que supo
adaptarse ante las adversidades más al
norte y cerca de la capital venezolana
cada 15 días cual hernández atraviesa la
autopista que une caracas con las
montañas del valle del tuy para llevarle
la leña a su mamá se dijo que no se
conseguía el galgo viene cada dos meses
cada tres meses que en la organización
tenemos que cortar la madera para poder
cocinar
como él otros venezolanos consiguen leña
en medio de las ciudades y crear en sus
cocinas al aire libre para hacerle
frente a la falta de gas venezuela es el
octavo país del mundo con más reservas
de gas al tener cerca de 197 millones de
pies cúbicos pero el que más abunda es
el gas metano que es diferente al que
sirve para cocinar
y en medio de la crisis energética los
cilindros de gas propano son cada vez
más escasos y costosas
200 niños que viven sin sus padres en
parís y que hacen parte de un grupo de
menores desfavorecidos fueron llevados
por la organización benéfica secours
populaire a un día de playa en campus la
normandía francesa
con el comienzo oficial del verano esta
iniciativa comenzó hace más de 40 años
para motivar a los niños que provienen
de familias en complejas situaciones de
estrés y pobreza a disfrutar las
vacaciones el concepto de vacaciones es
muy importante para los adolescentes
porque representa una historia que
compartir con sus otros compañeros así
que un día de sol y playa cae muy bien
para estos niños muchos de ellos no
conocían el mar
hay mucha gente hay muchos pájaros es
demasiado hermoso
nunca había estado aquí nunca en mi vida
es la primera vez que veo el mar por eso
vine hoy
también te hace olvidar el estrés porque
estaba un poco estresado al comienzo del
año escolar pero ahora está bien estoy
mejor
este es el panorama de los más
vulnerables de esta semana en el mundo
son miles de millones las personas que
enfrentan esta pandemia en frágiles
condiciones y el alivio solo es relativo
gracias por seguirnos recuerden que más
información la pueden encontrar en
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
[Música]